ich hoffe ihr seid fit ich bin es nicht
vielleicht macht sich alles bezahlt nur
wenige minuten später ich bin noch müder
wir fragen euch wahrscheinlich warum ich
so früh auf den beinen bin und zwar ist
mal wieder neuer trainer block spanner
berlin
weihnachten ihr euch wahrscheinlich
schon denken können sind wir in berlin
angekommen und zwar bei elia ab manchmal
was cooles ziemlich auch cool weil ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich warum
wir in berlin sind da sind wir wie beim
köln heute gegen union berlin spielt und
wir haben da karten bekommen über einen
freund in einem stadion verlassen per
kamera und ein bisschen travel blockiert
berlin
für die kinder sind angekommen in der
nähe des stadions ist einfach schon bald
aber alle leute sind halt union berlin
verkündete einzige interviews in köln
[Musik]
76 willeke verloren 2 0
ach du heilige scheiße das ding dann
intelligenz nicht so
aber hey angekommen das andere spiel
hier am sonntag und zwar um gegen
paderborn und paramount hat das 1 0
gemacht hat die beiden sind bremen
fahren
wie geht es der katze dabei so junge ich
komme mit mähdrescher und rasieren dein
leben ein paar sekunden später ist hier
ganz normal ich will offen gerade um 31
über weihnachtsmarkt allerdings sei da
schon geschlossen zu vom baum gefallen
oder was da steht eine mülltonne ja auch
da auch da auch da auch ich habe
wir sind jetzt gerade in amman kibat und
wir haben das cocktail oder weniger
erholt aber es ist etwas uns verstehen
sie mal wieder die tollen eine kamera
ist man sieht mich absolut rein gar
nichts
wir sind jetzt schon wieder nehmen
sondern anderen da es ist sonntag und
ich hasse diesen fokus von dieser
kameras oder wenn ich auf jeden fall im
spiegel und ich wollte mal diesen hand
was leider hand waschen haben drei
wochen später bruder wasserhahn ich
wollte was ich aus wie ein ding mit
denen das überall teams zumal ich habe
heute irgendwie bisher nur scheiße
gebaut aber das ist ja auch immer der
fall wir werden auf jeden fall jetzt
gerade in der bar oben ich habe keine
ahnung was das von haller kommt leider
ist hier noch irgendwie so hinter aus
und ich hab noch nichts gegessen und
deswegen fahren und was essen die wurden
auf jeden fall entspannt geparkt hier
und der bildschirm ist auf jeden fall
auch entspannt zum fahren er was ist
denn in berlin gelungen dem hier ist
auch noch die bremse schrott also die
bremst auch nicht richtig bei dem hier
ist bremse auch schrott laufen als
fußball gott es ist halt der echt geil
dass ich jetzt so richtig anfangen zu
locken wo es stockfinster ist manchmal
was lustiges
weniger lustig allerdings werde ich ja
nicht nur heute sondern auch noch morgen
trotzdem brauchen wir haben unseren
dünger bekommen meine lieben freunde
hinten ist der eiffelturm wie bewertest
du den döner und hast gerade von 17 bis
32 nacht in berlin wir haben unseren
bürgern
und dann kommt nicht an
ja also das heißt die gegend zu welchem
typ sondern das war meine schwester
diesen run und ein bar mit meiner
schwester und noch mit zwei damen
freunden und beleuchten lassen weil ich
doch mein ding jetzt wieder beide
abgesetzt und gehen jetzt schlafen
worden
das geht ab berlin tätige treffen hüls
ich hab meinen koffer wir fahren jetzt
zu studio 71 also ilias arbeitgeber und
mein management und den arbeiten hier ja
ist ja musste deswegen sag mal auf
russisch allem ein name ist er ja und
ich mag fußball weiter als gern
[Musik]
diese ist auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
angekommen um 12 uhr mittags da oben
weil unsere suite erstmal gesund
kulinarisch frühstücken
den schotten
hier liegt so ein armer noch nicht wann
das eigentlich ganz cool und dazu auch
preise gehen ja sogar recht klar aber
dann
[Musik]
wo ist meine taktik etwas gekauft sogar
weil die entspannte stimmung hier auch
so weihnachtlich und war mit dem
lagerfeuer schmeckte kinderpunsch eine
kamera dabei
weihnachtssterne und der weihnachten
oder her geburtstag oder ostern oder
silvester menschen die sind jetzt gerade
noch bei einem anderen youtube wagen
gekommen und zwar schreibt mir die
kommentare
welcher das ist jonas und ich mache
weiter nicht verraten
jonas und ich mache auf jeden fall eine
kurze challenge und zwar habe ich mir da
wenig schon in berlin bin dann kann ich
all' den körperschwerpunkt fest mit
jonas machen genauso channel in dem
meine lieben freunde die challenge heißt
der challenge ihr habt ihr vielleicht
schon gesehen irgendwo auf facebook
instagram keine ahnung wo und zwar geht
es aber ganz einfach darum ich will so
angefangen direkt an mit ann-kathrin
dass die schwester vom markt weil in der
challenge geht es darum dass frauen das
angeblich schaffen aber männer nicht mit
beiden füßen davor jetzt mal ein fuß
hinter den anderen noch mal nach hinten
gemauert jetzt hier hinstellen jetzt den
kopf gegen die wand so dass du quasi im
rechten winkel
das ist so jetzt kommt der stuhl nämlich
dazwischen der stuhl ist dass du den
stuhl hoch heben jetzt auch ständen das
war voll easy aber dieser challenge
heißt es halt auch dass frauen das immer
hinkriegen aber männer halt nie
deswegen will als erstes probieren
wachsen zu machen jetzt kommt der stuhl
und jetzt musst du den stuhl heben und
nun muss hoch kommen mit dem stuhl
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also jonas macht das ganze jetzt auch es
steht auch direktor torsten richtiger
mann ist jetzt den stuhl anfassen
hochheben den stuhl und jetzt aufrichten
warte tust du gerade so hey du kriegst
es gerade nicht hin warte ich bis jetzt
auch noch was so probieren 12
und das ist auch richtig trends ohne
[Musik]
agio an der stelle wird die tschechische
beenden die klappen aber irgendwie auch
nicht
wir haben fertig gedreht bei jonas hat
gerade schon gesehen dass wir im taxi
saßen denn wir sind jetzt am bahnhof
wieder angekommen ist hat schon gesagt
einer der schönsten bahnhöfe in
deutschland wenn ich überlege in köln da
sitzen so viele obdachlose und komische
junkies rum
ja der zellen in zug sitzen zu der
wunderschöne bielefelder hauptbahnhof
ich bin aufgewacht und kartuschen und
auf einmal ok schau unter klinge direkt
mal in die besten blocker eu west ich
werde es aber auf jeden fall zurück nach
köln fahren wir nicht so also ja ich
falsch zurück nach köln aber ich beende
der stelle jetzt den block weil der
block ist schon lang genug und ich
glaube auch schon wieder seit ein paar
tagen
ich weiß nicht andere sorgen von morgens
bis abends nicht lockt immer mehr gern
so ein sieben tage am stück gefühl
vielleicht noch also gefallen damit ich
mich sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von
euch an der stelle unter dem video hier
freuen schreibt nicht einfach unter den
kommentaren das cool findet wenn ich ab
und zu einfach ein paar tage blogge weil
ich da von ihm einen kanal bis nach köln
ok bis dann
[Musik]